I have followed baseball all my life for
cognate life and it really is a fun
sport and to me the baseball hall of
fame is the greatest Hall of Fame there
is period in two paragraph so I wanted
to write about it and wanted to do a
book an oversized coffee table book
stealing a line from some one of the
seinfeld episodes it even comes with
four legs in case you need a coffee
table book big pictorial history I'm
writing the history and I'm taking the
reader on a virtual tour through the
hall of fame and I am proud of the fact
that i've got a blurb on the back from
Yogi Berra which reads what Burt sugar
doesn't know about baseball nobody knows
I have no idea what that means I think
it's jen might like it's not worth
knowing but yo he makes sense i'm a yogi
ism but yogi my once as you i said yolks
what did you mean when you said when you
come to a fork in the road take it he
said that's easy island i live at the
end of a circle whether you go left or
right you come to my driveway i went
he's making sense and if you parse
analyze yo he sayin he does make sense
he's credited with it's too crowded
nobody goes there anymore well there's a
story to that the Yankees after a night
game will go out to dinner they'd be at
the stadium early to either go through
the lineup of the opposing team or get
treated for some ailment or wrap their
knees if it was Mickey Mantle or
whatever and after the game they'd all
go out to dinner and it was this one
restaurant in Cleveland that always was
open and always had a place for him
after a game and they all went there
well it became known that the Yankees
eat here you know advertising or word of
mouth and they went one time and there
was no place at the end
or so they didn't go there anymore ergo
it's too crowded nobody goes there
anymore meaning of Yogi makes sense
I really don't think steroids are as big
a problem as the presses made them and
if they are we've got a pitcher on
steroids going to a batter of steroids
as hitting to a fielder on steroid
you're looking for not one-upsmanship
Tony Gwen will tell you years ago the
Padres used to have a bowl event
Federman's in their Clubhouse like
Eminem Jewish problem didn't help the
Padres at all you're not talented ain't
going to help nothing if your talent it
might give you a little edge but so will
a spitball baseball is always delton
edges the Phillies used to raise their
third-base foul line extra lime so that
richie ashburn Bunce would stay there
the Cleveland Indians used to grow the
grass hire a third base so al Rosen the
third baseman wouldn't break is his nose
or his fingers on every ground ball a
bit slow it down 1962 playoffs between
the Dodgers and the Giants by that time
los angeles dodgers san francisco giants
they watered the basepaths omari wills
couldn't get off to a fast start and
steal bases that's legal steroids aren't
you know I all right I I don't get that
excited about it I'm sorry you know and
I'm sold that when I heard the word
drugs the first time I thought they were
talking about aspirin